everyone is beautiful but some forms of
beauty are celebrated more than others
the british beauty council says there
have been some improvements the past 20
years but the industry still favors
those with caucasian tones
nude means to me
white with my skin color i find it hard
to match the specific skin color i end
up mixing colors just to find my white
sleeve it's a lot harder than it should
be like compared to all my friends who
are like say why nude would be um
paulson or ivory or like
maybe yeah the basia end of the spectrum
it's problems like this they're calling
a legacy of colonialism what i'm really
interested in is power celebrating
rather than tolerating your skin tone is
very political you're not worth being
catered to you're not worth being
marketed to it is very painful and
hurtful you know walking into a beauty
hall was pleasure and pain
all wrapped up into one the diverse
consumer makes up just under 20 percent
of the population with a disposable
income of 3.7 billion pounds a year
but almost 40 percent of black shoppers
say they struggle to find products
suitable for their face
and so like around a fifth of other
diverse consumers they go to specialist
shops
figures show at least 2.7 billion pounds
from this audience is untapped potential
a clear
ethnic beauty gap
entrepreneur has taken matters into her
own hands
going beyond diversity on billboards
she's built a brand catered to
multi-ethnic consumers the beauty
industry is absolutely still failing you
know people of color being inclusive is
hard it takes so much work when i used
to go to some of the factories and i
said okay i need a deeper or richer
shade of foundation they would sometimes
put black pigment i kid you not
in the formula because it is actually
harder to serve a community who doesn't
have you know a skin tone that has been
worked on so much this is oh we need to
be inclusive because people will get mad
some experts think unconscious bias
could be at play it can be human nature
people want to feel safe and they feel
safe with the people that look like them
sound like them or come from the same
backgrounds
not all bad
but clearly still some way to go saber
chowdhury sky news